what else happened this weekend man oh I
got nervous dude you know one thing
sometimes like um you know I'm trying to
deal with like you know meeting more
people and stuff like that when I'm out
just you know running around and in the
bathroom I'm fine I got that nervousness
you know I got that nervousness and
nerves it's basically like dirty
electricity that hides in your body and
I get it when I'm at the urinal you know
in the urinal is just basically a
special hole that they made and they put
like a pretty thing over it and you just
urinate into it it's by the wall and I
get up there man and I noticed I was in
Phoenix you know I'm I'm peeing at the
urinal
doing what I do you know letting God
just pull water out of my body through
the front of me and I couldn't go and
the two dudes that we all showed up at
the same law at the same time and then
they left they got finished you know
these fellas are all emptied out and I'm
still just standing there just riding in
I mean this is like a you know it's like
a river rodeo I'm trying to get that
river I'm trying to spark and I'm just
basically pushing as hard as I can just
like squeeze like pushing forward almost
like you would to try to do a duty but
you're doing it towards the front for
urine and I'm just pushing man I can't
get that you're in the fire I can't get
that match to strike that flint to steel
I can't get it and then those dudes
finish the second guys so now I'm still
staying here and you can still like the
first dudes had already washed our hands
and they left you know now the second
dudes or why I'm still there brah so now
I'm not even peeing I'm just some guy
who's been holding his dick for about
two minutes and that's that's crazier
when you think about it you know when
you think about the fact that then
you're just some guy who's been holding
on to his penis for two minutes around
other men there's nothing wrong with it
but there's nothing right with it insert
just you know that was something my dear
you know just I was just got gun-shy and
I noticed that my nerves will land right
there in my crotch a lot of time in my
see Raj you know right down there by my
baby bird by that spicy frog and that's
what I'll notice and that started
happened to me again so I'm a little bit
worried sometimes about how I'm dealing
with anxiety but I think a lot of that
is just I got to start taking him some
better care of myself and so I got into
some physical fitness you know because
one thing is my mind hasn't been doing a
super great like very you know I've just
been I've been in my head too much well
thanks for watching that video right
there that was a beautiful little
segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe subscribe